I just [ __ ] love that one facility
because they said this is like Molotov
just don't complain when your business
doesn't grow that much over the next
decade
you're not eating your business you're
feeding yourself good
but you better [ __ ] shut up about why
am I not growing you know why you're not
really you're not eating
I think most people fear it being tough
when they're asking for something crazy
do you know how hard it is to be a
millionaire it's it's unbelievably hard
99% of people in the world never even
remotely get close number one biggest
mistake all of you make is you don't
realize it's gonna take 21 years for
success 21 years ago now look most
people don't understand what it is to do
a million
everybody thinks everyone should do a
million a million a million I laugh at a
million 99% of the people watching this
video right now for 31 years from now
because everything will be online will
never taste a million ninety-nine
percent of you now when you internalize
that all of a sudden now you're gonna
respect what you're asking yeah I want
people to respect their audacious
ambitions more I think the answer is to
not over judge yourself and to follow
what you feel so you focus on doing you
know focus on the business but then then
if you wait you know six months and it
feels good and you're like you know what
I can sneak an eating disorder of course
and real quick you know don't don't hold
somebody's opinion higher than your
feelings just if you want to do it do it
I just because even if it fails you'll
feel good yeah right do you understand
even if it fails you'll feel good I'm
patient which is a strength um I don't
judge others but most of all I don't
judge myself when I when people talk
about my superhuman time management I'm
actually terrible at it it's just that I
don't judge myself in my terribleness
the first way I always tell solopreneurs
they can grow is by making less money
personally I don't know your living
situation or how you live your life but
if you're going on this journey to build
a business the business matters more
than you so I would want the roof over
your head to cost you less money
I would like the food that put you put
in your mouth to cost less money you
have to look at everything else you're
doing in your life and I mean this like
you know how much time you spend a month
you said those four things how much time
do you actually spend on it in a day
zero
sometimes I assume in a week how much do
you spend on two hours great now is the
most important part of this meeting how
many hours do you sleep at night
great so I love the way you said it I
have to have seven so if I wanted to say
go to six so that you pick up five
you're gonna say to me Gary I have to
have seven right now let's go somewhere
else I have to know what you're doing
the other 17 hours I would bet the house
that we can find an hour every day I
guarantee it because you might be
working all 17 hours but you might not
be working on something smarter than
spending an hour a day on the thing that
you're talking about
do you understand that's I mean look
that's the answer the answer is time you
know people talk about working hard and
working smart the answer is only both
you have to work hard and smart based on
your ambition if you want to build a
business for yourself that is like a 1%
life most people understand what
building a business for yourself is it's
very special
it's very special trying to build a
business for yourself everybody's doing
now pulling it off trying to play
basketball everybody can try being an
NBA player trying to be a rapper or a
singer everybody's doing pulling it off
trying to be a footballer an actress
got it so you're trying great pulling it
off is hard it takes everything time and
smarts you need seven I'm glad you said
it that way because this makes this
piece of content more valuable
it's the 17 other hours I'll give you an
example a lot of people drive to work
for 45 minutes if they took a bus for an
hour and 15 minutes they would save
money and get more work done
but do you have the humility to take the
bus versus driving your car when you're
letting other voices dictate your
behavior it's always a bad idea
this is scary great sure but what's the
scariest thing you're wrong and you lose
and your company goes out of business
like sure but but I think that if you
like I would tell you you have to do
what feels right to you and if it
doesn't feel right to take outside money
and have all these voices then don't
it's The Tortoise and the hare either
you're a rabbit or you're a turtle the
turtle wins that's how the story ends
that took that go read the book the
turtle wins this is this is how you do
it okay I got it yeah
[Music]
CDE must Ferdinand Neil I love me I
might do you but me I like mangosteens
so so good if the dream this is actual
real she was like bringing a mango like
so you're not gonna invest as much as
properly needed because you want to buy
stuff by the way
Mazel Tov enjoy you do you but that's
the debate yeah because I love people
sick come on for my confessor but I just
[ __ ] love the facility this is this
is my Molotov just don't complain when
your business doesn't grow that much
over the next decade yeah
you're not eating your business you're
feeding yourself good but you better
[ __ ] shut up about why am I not
growing you know why you're not growing
you're not feeding it so they answer
your question why do I do it cuz I love
the process more than the other stuff
you love the other stuff more than the
process that's okay I don't think I'm
right that's just who we are so I'll
probably build billion-dollar companies
and you won't doesn't mean I'm right you
might have more vacations and eat more
food and go to more matches and spend
more time with people that's great life
is about choices but you can't have both
and I think when there's a moment in
time that's special like this it's
probably a good idea to take advantage
of it because you can go back to being
comfortable three years later and oh by
the way that comfortable tends to be far
better than it was three years earlier
there Trude we're just getting started
feels like you lost a little pep to your
step a humbling experience
d-roc
and I love that which is why if you
notice where I told them I said that's
great but don't you better not be
confused while your business is flat
you're siphoning all the money
here's comfort zones well of course
people forget nobody which is why most
people are not successful like like like
this is not complicated like the math is
in a very obvious place like most people
don't get to a million dollars of
earnings let alone per year and they do
the same behavior and they're confused
it's it's it's not a subtle tactic
everyone's looking for a [ __ ] tactic
like a hash tag or a [ __ ] algorithm
is gonna [ __ ] change it it's not that
it's a [ __ ] complete mindset and
lifestyle of humility and [ __ ]
process like it's [ __ ] hard because
it should be hard
it should be hard to rock I understand
you stop caring about what other people
thought yes
this assist of mine and I thought I
could make it work overnight
I told who because I thought it was a
business that's right
I talked but it was really tough for me
I think
and I will my dead and and
change like I know after I've made to it
it's not going to be overnight success
that's right yes so thank you so that I
will not be a [ __ ] I actually be the
expression for others and you have a
very powerful story because what you
what you who already live your truth is
something that a lot of kids go through
which is because it started off a
certain way you already taste it letting
somebody down which to a lot of people
is the biggest fear yes of course
but but I know what's so powerful is
you're in so early just because you had
a loss early on you can overcome that
very easily you really caught my
[ __ ] like my dad knows that yes I
didn't want everybody to know that it's
fine and they were posting online
but right now I'm posting it on me so
then every day because once you tell
your truth instead of having fake you're
no longer a prisoner to your face yes
alright it's alright these nice taster
need to sleep now because I always tell
my dad lose weight but I never do it
until now and I'm posting on my
everything
to just be there you know to let people
know that not push anyone for the change
in yeah and to be their fire slated to
shake your hand but I'm not sure can you
hear me I did something that I have to
accomplish yeah like like do something
very heavy from how what about when you
say I called out your [ __ ] in the
beginning did you accept it right away
or was it no he was it was a journey why
it was tough for me to accept that I was
a motion yes because like my ego is too
high of course and I even won what about
with my content do you hate it at first
I love you so much
I mean I never say I don't action and so
what happened
do you know I just know that it was I
really
yep and maybe we'll switch
yep so I'm turning 21 they say they they
say that I can afford different the last
year anymore so I would have to leave
the country or my job but the drama is
and drop out from high school so it's
really it's also part of me who become
magic and children or any background so
I like and there was a stretch for me as
I it's time for the action inside to
make things make things change and to
like really same five to five women like
you don't ya know that's exactly right
that's exactly right
you must totally understand I totally
understand especially I feel so so
amazing image outside I don't know who I
am like really inside me it was funny at
home so I feel like yeah Greek I'm free
enough
so yeah I just want to thank you like so
much this is what I always want to see
by this why I volunteer to Chinese I
don't even know that was run by marry me
yeah because um I should get in touch
with skyper yes yes I didn't know that
was your official that is what I like
give you value in some way thank you so
much I'm so happy I'm so happy for you
welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you the thing that people need to
understand more than anything is what is
driving their ambition why are you doing
what you're doing what are you trying to
scratch are you trying to be successful
to prove the people that wouldn't are
you trying to be successful because you
love the process are you doing it
because you want to buy something fancy
to show people that you're successful
why do you do what you're doing and most
of all for who
[Music]
so why the [ __ ] am I gonna listen to
anybody and I promise you you're living
that same life to do the [ __ ] thing
that you want to do stop [ __ ]
listening to other people start
executing get your head right and really
get perspective
you're a [ __ ] miracle do something
with it I [ __ ] love you Singapore
stop [ __ ] around and take advantage
of your life
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
thank you do something
[Music]